in xenophon's work the
symposium one of the characters who is
depicted and who tells us
a bit about his own frame of reference
and way of life is
antisthenes who is viewed by many as the
first cynic a student of socrates
who took on certain features of the
socratic approach to life
and then transformed it into its own
philosophical
school so we find some interesting
things coming up
in book three and and particularly in
book four where
antisthenes gives a longer
although rather short speech about the
way he looks at for example
wealth so in book three uh during this
drinking party that's what a symposium
is socrates is saying
nobody objects to the proposal that each
of us should state what he
thinks is his most valuable area
of expertise calius has said that they
can dine with him
if we give a display of our expertise
and calius says
if each of you will inform the company
what beneficial thing
you're an expert in so they all have to
say what
what it is that they're literally
bringing to the table
and there's a couple who talk about
matters and then antisthenes is going to
interrogate them in a bit so
calius says let me tell you
what i am most proud of i believe i can
make
people better that's a good thing right
so antisthenes says teaching them what
some manual skill or true goodness and
then kalia says
the latter if true goodness means
morality or you know
how to live and antisays of course it
does
most unquestionably courage and
cleverness are admitted to be sometimes
injurious both to one's friends and
one's country
moral goodness has no connection at all
with
wickedness and so calia says okay good
and then nicaratus
talks as well and he says well i have a
skill my dad made me memorize homer the
odyssey
and the iliad isn't that great i can now
repeat by heart the entirety of these
works and antisthenes says
don't you understand that rhapsods all
know these poems rhapsodes are people
who interpret the poetry
for other people and he says how how
could i not know it when i listen to
them almost every day
and then he says do you know any class
of people sillier than they are and
nicaratus says
no i don't think that i do but then
socrates comes in with a save and he
says
no because they obviously don't
understand the underlying ideas
but you've paid a lot of money so that
none of the important points has escaped
you and he allows nicaratus to you know
think that
he's got something really valuable there
so then
when when antisthenes is himself asked
about
what is the valuable thing that he has
you know since other people are talking
about good looks and stuff like that
uh what does antisthenes say that that
he
himself has he says my wealth
and now this is kind of a weird thing
for him to say
because he's not a rich guy so
how is it he's priding himself on his
wealth
how is that something that he's bringing
to the table
is it's going to turn out it's something
that he's learned
in part from socrates also by living
and it's something that can be shared
with others
he can even make a loan on the scanty
wealth that he has
in book four we find out how that's the
case and we should pick up the story of
calius and nicaratus
a little bit first calius is the one
who's you know actually
helping people out and hosting them so
calia says i spend the time
making people morally better socrates
says well how do you do that
and he says by giving them money i help
them out
by giving them money and in a way this
this is some
you know you can you can understand this
giving people money
allows them to do things that could make
them better people
it certainly keeps them from needing to
steal
in order to you know feed themselves or
clothe themselves
and you know uh antisthenes says do you
think people keep morality and their
minds are in their pockets and cali says
in their minds
so how are you making their minds
morally better by putting
money in their pockets and he says well
because they know they've got something
with with which to buy what they need
they don't need to risk committing
crimes
and then he says do they repay all that
they get from you and cal
calia says no no they don't at all and
he says do they do you favors in return
for your money
oh no no they don't do that either some
of them are even more hostile than they
were before
so antisthenes says that's a weird thing
so you can make them better people but
they're only better to other people
not to you their benefactor and the
hint there is well you're not really
making them better people
nicaratus kind of gets off the hook
because here we go you can hear from me
now
how you'll be improved if you associate
with me you know i presume that within
the poems of that greatest of sages
homer is information about practically
every aspect of human affairs
so if you want to become a good estate
manager politician or general
or become like achilles or ajax or
nestor odysseus
give me your attention i have this
knowledge he can
he can quote the right passages to help
you
do all of these great things
then antisthenes says do you know how to
be a king too
just because you're aware that homer
praised agamemnon is both a good king
and stout warrior
and this doesn't really go anywhere in
terms of criticism
but you can see some parallels here too
like how plato is going to have socrates
treated in
iron treating by socrates in in
that dialogue by that name the ion
when they get to antisthenes after going
through several other people
he says something rather paradoxical
so he's going to tell us about his
wealth socrates says
you tell us how it is you pride yourself
on your wealth although you have such
limited means so you don't have a lot of
money you don't have a lot of property
how are you wealthy and how is this
something that is
beneficial and antis
notes a number of different things so
first he talks about
cases of wealthy and
powerful people and he says i believe
it's not in their estates that people
have wealth or poverty
but in their minds i see many people who
though they have
very great wealth they consider
themselves so poor
they submit to any hardship in any
hazard with view to increasing their
possessions
i know of cases of brothers who have
inherited equal shares
and then you know one is one is more
than enough to cover his expenditure the
other is indigent
i even observe despots who are so hungry
for wealth they commit far more dreadful
crimes
than the desperately poor so
having wealth having power doesn't
actually make you
wealthy if the measure is being driven
to
acquire even more wealth if you'll sell
yourself out or sell out your
your brother or your country person in
order
to make more money you're really a poor
person you don't even though you might
have a
million dollars in the bank account if
you need to have another
10 or 20 or million more you're not
you're not rich
right so that's a big issue and he talks
about this as being like a person who's
got a ton of food
but is still eating all the time they're
never reaching the limit
of their appetite they're never
satisfied and this is kind of
interesting it's kind of paradoxical
why do we want money we don't we
shouldn't want it just for its own sake
because it's no good for anything
you know it's whether it's electronic
stuff it's just a bunch of you know ones
and zeros
or if it's paper money you know there's
only so much you can do with that or
coins
you know you want it so that you can
feel secure so that you can have a good
life right but if it's not providing you
with a good life
you're not really wealthy any more than
the person who's got a ton of food
and just keeps on eating it antisthenes
contrast his own
way of life to this saying that
i feel sorry for these people
the quantity of my possessions is such
that i can hardly discover them
but i still have quite enough to satisfy
myself satisfy my
hunger when i eat to quench my thirst
when i drink to clothe myself so that
out of doors i'm no colder
than cali is here for his great wealth i
mean
you think about it this way if you have
one good winter coat
you're covered maybe boots and hat and
gloves too right
you need a up here and he says when i
get home the walls of my house seem to
me like a really warm
tunic the roof like a really thick cloak
my bed clothes are so adequate that it's
hard work even to wake me up
i don't need a mansion i don't need all
sorts of decorations
all i need is a place that's got the
creature comforts that i'm looking for
and i don't really care he would go on
to say if you know we were putting it in
his mouth today
i don't care what color my blanket is or
whether my pillows
are you know from this company or that
company
or how you know how pretty my bed is
it's for sleeping in you know the roof
it's for
keeping rain off my head he even goes on
to talk about sexual matters and he says
if my body feels the need for sexual
intercourse i am
so content with what is available that
any women
i approach welcome me with open arms
because nobody else will go near them so
he's saying
if if sex is what i want i'm not going
to be picky about it
i'll sleep with whoever's going to be
cool with that
and you know they'll they'll be happy
all be happy
we don't have to make a big thing of it
and he says mark you i find pleasure in
all these things that my prayer would be
to enjoy doing each of them not more but
less i have such feeling that some of
them give me more pleasure than is good
for me
and then he goes on and he says not only
am i satisfied
i actually enjoy my pleasures more
because i can wait for them so i i don't
actually eat until i do get hungry
and then the food tastes better i don't
drink until i get thirsty i don't have
to
stimulate myself i just see where the
the appetites that i do have and will
indulge in a
moderate way are going to lead me and
then i can enjoy them more he gives the
example
at this dinner party he says
just now i'm drinking this thousand wine
which is like one of the better kind of
wines not because i'm thirsty but
because the opportunity presented itself
and i can i can have a good time
he also goes on and says listen it's
also easier if you don't have a lot of
demands like this to be moral in conduct
and this is going
back to calius's point about you give
people money you fill up their wallets
or their pockets
and then they're going to be good people
antisthenes is saying no no no that's
not the case at all
if you don't desire that much then
you're not going to be
reaching for everybody else's stuff you
can give people money
and they can still go out and steal
things they can still behave
badly towards their neighbor right
because they haven't figured out what
they really want and how to be satisfied
another thing he points out is he has
more spare time
and leisure to do what he wants which in
his case
he says to hang out with socrates and
here's where we get to something really
interesting
so remember a little bit earlier at the
start and tistony says
wealth is really in the mind at another
point he says when i want to have a good
time i don't buy luxuries in the market
i supply myself from my own mind i rely
on what i've got to think about
thinking is free so he talks about
socrates
and he says um so this is the kind of
wealth that makes people generous
socrates from whom i obtained it didn't
supply me by quantity or weight but
handed over to me as much as i could
carry away
what are we talking about there
discourses
ideas things we can lock away in our
head
and bring out for ourselves to think
about antisthenes was famous for being
able to like
have conversation with himself that was
one of the things that he said he
learned from philosophy
he's learning that from socrates that's
something he can give to other people
as he's doing in this this very dialogue
when antisthenes finishes his speech
then
calius says i envy your your wealth
first the state doesn't impose tasks on
you
second people aren't angry if you don't
lend them anything and then nicaratus
says
don't envy him you'll see me get a loan
from him
of his faculty for needing
nothing isn't that an interesting idea
you can loan out to other people
this way of living you have this knack
this understanding and uh you're not
actually losing anything by lending it
to them you're
you're really just giving it to them or
replicating it in them
so this according to antis this is where
real wealth lies it's not in having a
ton of money it's not in having
you know multiple houses or a garage
full of cars or
you know a whole bunch of shoes or
whatever it's going to be
right it's it's being able to be
satisfied
with what you do have
you